hello YouTube chest Lois muffins
this is grunge in here welcome to the
18th episode of dirty chest tricks this
is the last and the final episode of my
trickier prota against the French
defense which arises after the Mordor
efore Essex and here my recommendation
is you play the two knights attack
system which start with the Moon Knight
to f3 defy and now the move Knight to c3
now all the side line moves which I have
highlighted by the green arrows I have
covered in my earlier dirty chests
Trixie's 16th and the 17th episode so if
you haven't watched them I strongly
insist you to watch those videos and
then continue with this video in this
video we are going to concentrate on the
main line which arises after the move
Knight to f6
which is in fact choice of many hiring
player and specially players above 2000
now against this move I'm going to show
you a very high profile trick which you
certainly want to consider it in your
fili rating tounament the reason is the
line is very forceful 1 it has a
tremendous amount of depth and so far I
have catch few title players with this
string so you can see the potential of
this line ok here white will continue
with the movie 5 so attacking the knight
and the most of his response from the
black is Knight to d7 where we have to
continue with the mundi form here black
responds with the move C Phi so this is
all pretty much theory the Steines
variation of the French defense and here
I'm going to suggest a very tricky move
that is Bishop to g5 now especially if
you are playing a short version of the
game there is a chance that your
opponent immediately played this move
that is Bishop to e7 which is outright
mistake the simple refrigeration is you
simply take this bishop and after Queen
recaptured
now you can see this juicy hole on d6
where you are going to plonk your night
better ease after the move Knight to b5
so we have two threats and in fact
blacken or parry both of them so for
example let's say if black tries to play
the move Knight to a6 saving the folk
then we can play Knight to d6 check King
to f8 and after Bishop captures pawn
captures and the move c3
Northerly white consolidate his pawn
shield but black has a double pawn on
the Queen side and his King is clearly
misplaced
so Bishop to e7 is a big big mistake at
this point now as for the theory the
menu over here is Queen to b6 but if you
opponent plays other moves for example
let's say Queen to c7 or Queen to e5
then I have covered a sample line
against those variation in the PGN which
is available in the description so
kindly go through the PG so the only
movie are continuing over here is Queen
to b6 after that white is going to play
a very tricky move that is D cap to C
Phi and at first sight it looks suicidal
because not only you are giving up the
center but it allowed black to develop
his piece with a temple but there is a
cute point behind it now the first thing
you need to know is at this point black
cannot capture in the B to pawn if we
capture the B to pawn then our first
tricks come into the picture that is you
play the Moon Knight to be 5 so we have
a threat on c7 square and if black plays
here
Knight to b6 then the simplest is you
play a rook to be even so the only
square left for the Queen is to take the
a to pawn and afterwards we are
continuing with the move rook to even
hitting the Queen again and if white
once white can have the draw easily but
why it has a better response after Queen
to be to the lethal move rook captures
a6 and white is a clear piece of
the reason is black cannot capture this
piece because at the end
Blackie will be checkmated so Queen to
b2 is not possible that list with only
reply that his Bishop captures c5 and at
first sight it looks like Y has made a
blunder because now black is attacking
to sports and it's nearly impossible for
y could defend both the sports anyways
white will continue with his tricky
journey with the move Queen to d2 now
especially when you playing a classical
game where opponent has a ample time to
think about it
he will definitely play the move Bishop
captures f2 and in fact this is the best
move in the situation as for the engine
now instead of Bishop captures ups -
what happens if black plays other moves
such as castle or nc6 well I'm afraid
they are not as good as Bishop captures
f2 and once again I have covered those
lines in the pgl so later on you can
have a look at them now Queen to b2 has
the same problem as earlier I want you
to pause this video and find out what is
wrong with this move ok I hope you find
this mu that is rook to be one attacking
the Queen Queen to a3
now Knight to be far hitting the Queen
and it looks like black is doing counter
attacking with the move Queen to e2 but
after night to c7 check so the Queen has
to go to the effort square and now you
simply save your roof with the move rook
to c1 and white emerge here with at
least and exchange okay let's see what
happens after Bishop captures f2 well
blacks idea over here is when white
capture the piece after Queen catches f2
black will play this wonderful move
Queen captures b2 so attacking two
pieces which cannot be defined by the
white at the end black will emerge with
a two-point advantage and indeed it's
true black is going to regain his piece
with an advantage
but White has amazing trick up the
sleeve can you guess why it's next move
it's unbelievable that White has this mu
that is king - D - so sacrificing the
whole rook whoa
well what's the big idea now the first
thing you have to notice over here that
black cannot decline this because if he
plays moves such as Knight to c6
then after a simple move Bishop to d3
white is going to connect his rook and
now black is a simple piece down I want
a very quick game against a high-rated
where the game continues with the moon
nightcap - C Phi but after Knight
captures Knight captures and queen to C
fires so there's a mate on e7 black
block the maid with the moon f6 but to
his horror he find out that after a roof
has to be one that lost the Queen so you
can see this line is very forceful one
as after Bishop captures f2 it's a kind
of black who fallen into the quicksand
where to come out he has to play so many
accurate moves okay Queen captures even
what else and here comes the second
stunner can you find why it's next reply
well it's amazing that if I can play
over here Bishop to b5 and sacrificing
second rook hahaha soul is he
well once again blacken or decline this
offer because if he plays the move such
as Queen to be - then after Queen to c5
so we are threatening a mate on e7 and
after the move f6 he kept his f6 and G
capture step 6
and Bishop captures f6 there is no way
what can say this mate
so the forcing move again black has to
accept the second rook that is Queen
captures h1 and now the whole idea of
white is revealed after the next move
that is Queen to C file so white is
simply threatening Queen to e7 checkmate
and
believe it or not but it looks so scary
even the white is allowing this chat
that is Queen captures v2 and after King
to c1 if you call the pieces at this
point white is to Rukh and three points
down but still willing that's the beauty
about this line okay in order to save
the mate black has to give up the Queen
so either black and clear over here
Knight to c6 first win captures g5 in
any order but the result will be same so
for example here black continue with the
MU Queen captures g5 and after Knight
captures White has a threat of capturing
the bishop if Knight to a 6 then Queen
to d6 is a very strong reply in other
words black has to forcefully play the
Moon Knight to c6 afterwards White is
going to capture this night after be
recaptured and queen capture we are
hitting the roof so the force replies
rook to b8 and still at this point it
looks like leg is fine because black has
a two extra pawn but the problem over
here is his species are not coordinated
and this is where white explored the
nature of the game by following dazzling
reply I hope you guessed it
yes it's Knight captures to defy boom
well instead of Knight captures defy you
can also play the move Knight captures
ecigs but it leads to a Royce position
and I have covered this line in the PGN
so kindly go through it so here we are
going to concentrate on the moonlight
cactus d5 now this is the sacrifice
which black cannot deny
for example if let's say black plays the
move Bishop to b7 at this point then the
simplest replies you play in Knight to
c7 check and after King to ever fade
Queen captures Knight bring leads to the
checkmate and instead of Bishop to b7 if
black players move such as castle at
this point then this is also a blunder
move the simple reason is after Knight
to e7 check King to h8 and night
to see eight it blackly kept to the
piece then we take the night and remain
ahead in material so black has to
forcefully play the Moon Knight to e5
but after Queen to b4 so we are
threatening checkmate on at seven so
black has to play in Knight to g6 but
after Knight to d6 once again white
emerged with extra material and winning
position okay let's consider the most
critical reply er that is e captricity 5
well afterwards it's very obvious that
fight is going for the throat and the
movie should play is e 6 and black
response is force black cannot accept
this pawn the simple reason is after F
captures c6 and Queen captures a 6
if King too afraid then Queen to f7 is a
checkmate so the force reply over here
is King to d8 afterwards we have the
following sequence that is Knight to g7
check so [ __ ] king and rook King to
c7 now we will enjoy some King dance
after Queen check King to b7 Queen check
King to c7 Queen check came to b7 and
finally we take the rook point is this
PCs are misplaced and black King side
points are about to disappear so the one
game continues over here with the move
Knight to b6 attacking the Queen
I played Queen to e4 check and after
King to c7 and Queen captures pawn I
managed to capture the g7 pawn with the
ease and then slowly advance my H pawn
and win the game okay any other moose
doesn't make any sense you can check out
with your computer the only move which
keep the black in the game that is AB 6
well now think about this trick so far
we have played 18 moves and how many of
your opponent's are going to play this
much accurate until 18
even though they are title player I
don't care to see this line in that much
death it's really really hot and that's
why this is very very effective even in
the feed a tuna ministry well after f6
I'm determining that you should continue
with the move Queen to d6 so we have a
simple idea that we want to capture this
note and then capture the rook
so black doesn't have time to capture a
piece the force supply over here is rook
to b6 afterwards we are going to capture
this night and after Bishop recapture we
are going to play the move wind can't
justify haha so still black doesn't have
time to capture this piece because we
have Queen check coming up nabbing the
rook in the corner so black has to first
defend his rope with the move rook to f8
and now we are going to play the move
Knight to e4 and it's really amazing
that after sacrificing your two rooks if
you look at this position it's more or
less equal but the engine will give
slight advantage to the white the only
reason is this PCs are not coordinated
they are sitting in the back rank and
not doing anything now to illustrate the
power of this position I like to show
you my game where I beat a feeder master
where he continued with the move g5
I continue with the moon night to see
fire so hitting the bishop he played
bishop to see head and now I start
attacking black Queen side with the move
a for my opponent responded with the
move to f7 he desperately wants to
activate his rooks no matter I continue
with the move a 5 he played a rook to b4
and now a very strong move that is
Knight to e4 so White's idea is to
create a family folk and in fact this
position is almost lost to the black in
the game my opponent was in the time
trouble and he played this horrific
blunder that is root 2 e 7 kindly pause
the video and find a finishing blow ok I
hope you find this easy continuation
that is light we have 6 check
came to her faith and now queen 2g8 is a
checkmate and this is what happened when
the king is naked and playing around the
border well I hope you like this very
high profile trick in the French male
line now the best part is if you check
this line in mega database 2016 there
are hardly few games played in this line
that's why it is a big surprise weapon
for you in the professional tournaments
well good luck to you for playing this
line in your game thank you for watching
this video feel free to like subscribe
and comment on my video and I'll meet
you very soon bye and take care
you that see captors v4 create amazing
high profile trick just in the fourth
move the game then you will be amazed so
let's say here we start with the move c6
followed by the d6 Queen goes to the c7
square and meantime when white plays
Knight to f3 we are going to pin that 9
with Bishop to g4